and we will be talking about a new topic
today
and uh that's polymers um and we're
going to start
by talking about there's what i want to
do is cover two
ways that we humans make polymers
and uh uh and the first way has to do
with something called a radical
so that's why i want to start our story
and what is a radical okay
well a radical
is a molecule that has
one or more unpaired electrons okay
so one or more
unpaired
electrons but
as you can imagine if i've got an
unpaired electron it's kind of like a
broken bond
you know it's kind of like a broken bond
that's a radical
and and you could also imagine that a
broken bond wants to not be broken
right so so it's going to try to find
something to bond to
and that's why we got radicals all in us
all the time
some sometimes they're important but
sometimes they can cause a lot of harm
right and that's why if you eat
blueberries
then you get these things called
antioxidants
right and antioxidants that's just one
of many many types of antioxidants
what do they do they go and they give
these radicals what they need
what they're looking for an electron
they give them an electron and they
don't mind
they don't become radical themselves
they just simply stop
the radical from being radical now why
does this matter well we're gonna see
what that means for polymers but let's
make a radical so
imagine and i'm going to go lewis on us
because i want to see the electrons
i'm going to go lewis so imagine i've
got methane
well methane looks like this
nice and happy oh the octet
ah but now i
introduce a chlorine atom
so i've got now chlorine and chlorine
is is hungry chlorine wants
to fill its octet by itself right
and so what does it do it's like well
you know i'm powerful i'm strong i'm
just going to grab
from methane it sees methane and it's
like okay you give me
one of your electrons how about that as
a deal
and here we go and
here we go and it takes it in the form
of the hydrogen
and so we got this like this
and like this okay
oh the chlorine got really happy but
look at what happened to the methane
but it lost an electron and a hydrogen
with it
and it has an unpaired electron
that electron is not hap i mean you know
it just wants to bond to something
that's all you can't blame it
don't we all want that the problem is
that this really needs it badly
right and so this is called so what we
did is we took chlorine
and we combined it with with methane
and we made what's called a methyl
radical
so this is called that's called a free
radical
okay or in this case it's methyl because
that's what the chemistry is it's a
methyl radical
as we'll see you can make radicals out
of lots of stuff
just yeah take a hydrogen and electron
have a free
unpaired electron left and it's a
radical
i could start with ethane and make
an ethyl radical c2h5
right with a dot that dot is the
unpaired electron
and so on and so on and that's what you
know so if you have free radicals
and they come along and there's some
other molecule it's not going to be this
one but maybe there's something like an
antioxidant in those blueberries it's
going to come along and be like you know
i got electrons i could give you here
have one
i see how needy you are i see how badly
you want one
you can take one of mine and i'll be
fine i'll be fine
right or maybe we'll form a bond with
that
those are antioxidants but that's not
the topic the topic is we're making this
new material called the polymer
so how does that work well for to
understand that we got to make a radical
out of a special case we got to make a
radical out of a double bonded
molecule right so now i'm going from
methane to the double bonded
ethene now hang on let me put this up
here
and in the case of a double bond
something very important happens
something very important happens
and and the reason is that i've got two
bonds i've got two bonds not one well
that's what double bond
that is what double bond means right and
but i can now
because i've got a double bond i can do
something very important
i can do something very important when i
turn that molecule into a radical
something special happens so what i'm
going to do is i'm not going to call it
chlorine i'm going to just call it
r dot and because now we're making a
polymer and this is called
well it's got different names it's
called radical or sometimes you'll see
it as addition
polymerization and this is the first
kind of polymer i want to talk about
and so i'm going to you saw how it
worked with chlorine i'm just going to
say
i got something called r and it's called
a radical initiator and i'm going to
draw the dot there
right just like i had the dot on
chlorine this is going to be the radical
initiator
radical initiator
and i'm going to now bring this
to my double bonded molecule that's the
key
key is in the double bond so watch what
happens okay so first
here's what happens i've got r with its
dot
plus and again i'm going to go lewis i'm
going to have all those electrons in the
bonds
spelled out for you with dots all right
so r plus
c two pairs of electrons in there you
see that there's my double bond
right okay and here are the hydrogens
i'm not going to draw them every time
those sticks have hydrogens on the ends
okay but now see watch what happens so
now
this radical like the chlorine
it sees this electron and it says aha i
can take you
i can take you right now this
and and i will be happy if i take this
and
this double bonded molecule can't really
stop it from happening so the radical
now can bond
to the carbon over here right it's got
these two
those are those two two hydrogens that
were there
yeah but now watch what happens now i've
got here
here here and then i've got this
and i've got this
look at that but now this is a radical
because this has an
unpaired electron this has an unpaired
electron
and so often what we'll do is we'll
write this you know
well we'll often just write it i'm just
going to rewrite it
just because then it gets us in the mood
for what's going to happen next
as a single bond with the two hydrogens
and the radical sitting there i just
took this unpaired electron and put it
out in the end there
that's a radical again and i
haven't broken the bond that's the key
the double bond allowed a radical to
come in
take an electron make a new radical out
of the whole thing
and remain stable that's what the double
bond gave me right
so if i go to step two what happens
well if i go to step two well now i've
got
this r that's sitting here all right and
i've got these
uh here and i've got i'll put them in
explicitly
and there oh but see this is in a bucket
a bucket of these ch4 c2h4 molecules
they're all over the place and now this
is gonna see so we're gonna do that
and this is gonna see another one let's
put that one in here
here we go a double bond nice and happy
floating along
and this radical version of it sees it
and it says nope i need that electron
thank you very much
and so you get this right
single bond single bond
and we'll just put it out here
and so now how many did i have two four
and here's another one
and there it is and i've got another
radical
i've got another radical
the thing stays radical until
it finds another r dot right
that so this just goes on and on
and on this is a new radical
new radical and each
time it finds a double bonded
c2h4 molecule it can take it add it to
the chain
add it to the chain sometimes this is
called chain polymerization
addition polymerization radical
polymerization you see it's all the same
you see how it works
because i'm making a chain and i keep on
adding the same
building block the same molecule that's
really important
right the same molecule and then
etc okay etc
what how how long is it cetera well
typical
polymers go on for a long time
we're talking a minimum of a hundred
times a hundred
you might be able to draw that you know
all the way down maybe down to there
but a lot of polymers go to a hundred
thousand or a million
chain links a million right that makes
these
this class of materials extremely
unique and we're going to talk about
them
in the next you know over the next uh
well during this week
a couple well what i want to do is give
you a couple reasons why they're unique
and then we're going to go into my why
this matters
what we started with was a monomer in
this case
we started with ethylene or ethene and
so here was our monomer
okay and what we ended up with is
a polymer
and and in this case you know it it's oh
boy
i'll draw it straight like i did there
okay here we go here we go this is the
polymer
okay but see we don't i don't want to
write
a you know a hundred thousand carbon
letters on my page you can you can't
blame polymer chemist for that
and so what we do is we have a notation
where if if this was the monomer
one poly many mer
c2h4 okay then then what you do is you
take the monomer
and you write it in a special way to
show that it's become a polymer and you
put the monomer inside
right inside oh let's just write those
hydrogens
explicitly why not okay
there they are they were there too okay
and then
okay but now what you do is you put a
parenthesis
and and then to show that it's a polymer
this bond comes out the edge
right and that shows i had this monomer
now notice this is the same as a monomer
but a single bond
why because it that double bond to keep
on making it radical
i changed them all into single bonds
each time i made the chain longer
right so this and then we put an n
because it could repeat n times and
that's a polymer
so the the chain bonds are sticking out
of the edges like that of the
parentheses
yeah polymer chemists aren't as you know
the crystallographers you don't want to
upset
polymer chemists are fine so you know if
you if you put brackets there
yeah they're okay with it it's not so
bad parentheses
brackets the main thing is those bonds
that are polymerizing
those bonds that are that are forming
the chain have to come out
of the parentheses and then the little
end there is how many times
okay so a couple of things we can talk
about right
so monomer
well one thing a couple of things so the
molecular weight
is going to be high it's going to be
typically
and again you know thousands of grams
per mole because it's a mole
of the molecule this is a molecule
this is a molecule it's just a very very
long chain molecule
and so polymer people and bio people
they like using
so they like using daltons
one dalton
equals one gram per mole
why switch to daltons i don't know
but this it's just a unit thing so don't
get
confused a dalton is a grand primal a
kilo dalton is a thousand grams per mole
right okay so you know we can say like a
d
a a d a maybe they just like
the symbol d a or k d
a for kilo dollars this is grams for a
mole thousands of grams okay but
now it's easy but one long chain if i
know
the molecular weight right in grams per
mole then i kind of also could know how
long it is
right you know back and forth it's just
a molecule it's just that this is a very
very
big molecule and so sometimes you'll see
it called a macro
molecule macro it's huge
it's a long chain
i want you just think about how this the
length is
length is on the order of i'll spell it
out
microns right just think about it
we've been talking about a lot of
different materials in this class we've
talked about you know
a lot of different solid materials right
i got perfect crystals crystals with
defects amorphous materials
molecular solids this is another class
of solid but you can really
start to think about why this is so
different because if this thing
is a is a hundred thousand or a million
units long
that strand is is a very long piece of
spaghetti
and that means that that different
things can happen and that's one of the
reasons why polymers are so
uh interesting and can be so useful
and so if you think about taking it
longer this isn't even we're not even
close to how long
you know this is still just a little
longer but what i'm showing you is
something important if i've got
you know spaghetti that's that long you
better believe it can tangle up
and so when you think about one of these
strands or maybe a couple of them
they're gonna usually often not always
you can make crystals out of polymers
but a lot of times they're going to
tangle
because they're just so long
and the degree of the length by the way
that's another thing right
degree of
polymerization ah why was my o so big
there
i don't know it was it was a moment
i'm feeling it with the o and that's the
number
of mer yeah it's a polymer
mer units and
and that's per polymer and
this is average
average because
as you can imagine it's very i'm going
out to a million
did i hit a million or did i get 990 uh
thousand or did i get a million
a million and ten 10. it's not you don't
control the length exactly
and so the degree of polymerization is a
number that is the average
right it's it's the average it's the
same as the molecular weight
it's an average because the strands have
a distribution and we'll talk about that
more
on wednesday now i just want to get down
some
some polymer insights
okay so we got things like molecular
weight degree of polymerization
right now these are very long
and so you can imagine that it's going
you know it's kind of like glasses right
when we dig glasses these are really
long chains
you can imagine as a liquid that might
be pretty viscous
right that might be pretty viscous you
could also imagine that when you
solidify it it might be pretty
disordered or maybe crystalline
right you kind of might have some
similarities with glass again we'll talk
about that more wednesday
well the one thing i want to highlight
now is that what can happen because it's
so long is that you can literally get
what you can literally get like one
polymer chain
that finds itself wanting to form a
crystal
literally like in the middle of itself
and then it's like okay
i can stack and form a nice crystal all
but now i can't again
and now oh look i think i can pack in
nicely as a crystal
and now i can't again and it just goes
you could i could i'm really enjoying
this i could just keep going
that's one polymer strand
and it would keep going it literally
would
because it's like a hundred thousand
units long so you can imagine that
polymers
just one strand of a polymer can be
incredibly complicated
because it might have some regions that
are crystalline
and some that are amorphous and by the
way we know
that the crystalline region will be very
different right
this is going to have the lowest volume
per mole so this will have
maybe this will be the hardest maybe
it'll be the most brittle
right so that that does it crystallize
does it not
that's going to be something that's very
important
how much of it crystallizes right a
micron by the way the length is also
important
that's like visible light wavelength so
optical properties will depend on these
things
right and so what you have is this
this new form of matter
that we have in the last 50 years
engineered and
understood more and more how to control
and and just while you know so
we're talking about uh you know this
addition polymerization
this list goes on and on and on now
today
now so what is this list well these are
all
i want you to notice here monomer
okay this is the polymer name this is
the monomer
here's the polymer they should have put
parentheses there we'll excuse that
because you can feel that those are
going outside of the parentheses
or brackets right and then here's the
use
so what did we just do we just did
polyethylene polyethylene
is right there that's the polymer
polyethylene there's the monomer
right there's the polymer now notice
something about every single one of
these monomers
there it is they've all got that double
bond that double bonded carbon
so when i put a radical initiator in a
soup
of those monomers i can form polymer
chains
right i can form polymer chains and
those are the polymers
you make and notice they all start you
know these are the same
unit repeating over and over and over
again and notice the flexibility here
right so in polyethylene which is one of
the simplest cases is the most common
polymer
these are just a few uses now if i just
take
you know one of those hydrogens off of
one of the two carbons
right there's polyethylene up there
right if i just take one of the
hydrogens off
and instead i put a benzene ring
right so now i've got this
and oh boy did i draw that
yeah it's okay here's my hydrogens
coming off of the benzene
there you go there you go and there
and there and oh good
i've drawn polystyrene haven't i
no i have not
because you gotta come out
that's a polymer now it's a polymer
i came out
okay well that's pretty all i did is i
just took the polyethylene
and i and i put a benzene ring there and
i get styrofoam if i
if i put air through it as i make it
processing or i can make all sorts of
other things
out of it that's polystyrene that's
polystyrene
this is why polymers have been
have become such an incredibly important
and
and enormous part of our lives
because you can see if i just change the
monomer i just change one thing
in one molecule and then get a bucket of
those
i might completely change the solid that
comes out of it
but all sorts of things are going to
change you can imagine that just the way
the chain
folds up on itself like that maybe the
way the chain
comes and talks to another chain or
maybe a part of itself
when i say talk and i'm talking about
chemistry i mean bond
is it van der waals the the surface area
is enormous here the surface area of one
mile
we did this right we looked at boiling
points as you get a little longer
a little longer to like c-12 this is
this is see hundreds of thousands so so
the amount
of bonding london dispersion is enormous
right that's one of the reasons these
can be very strong but the tunability is
also enormous because
i can just swap in a different group
here and polymerize that
okay this is why this was so exciting
when it was
you know polymers were first made really
in the 40s and 50s
they really started coming into the
market in the 70s
on mass and i want to now i want to
tell you why this matters
we're going to start with a commercial
this is a this is an
ad on television
uh by pepsi in 1978 and i thought this
would be
a nice way to start my why this matters
it's only 30 seconds
oh
pepsi cola's new 2-liter plastic bottle
it's tough
really tough
and besides being tough pepsicola's new
2-liter plastic bottle is 25
lighter than glass it's tough and light
tough and light now apart from some
other
potential differences you may have
noticed with today's times
um that was the key that was one of the
keys
right so so they could make pepsi could
and coke coca-cola
could make bottles that were lighter
than glass but
not break that was a very big deal that
was a very big deal
right and they really started in a lot
of ways they started the revolution
right of of plastics and polymers
in uh in commercial products
um now uh
if you if you fast forward to today i
just want to show you how bottles are
made right that's a two liter bottle
here is a two liter bottle making plant
and and i think it's always interesting
to see how what you're buying is
actually made right so here's
here's just a little shortcut almost
instantly thanks to a built-in cooling
system
these preforms are now on their way to
becoming single serving juice bottles
[Music]
this is another plastic injection
molding machine
it uses the same method to make
pre-forms for a different model
one and a half to two liter bottles
[Music]
the preforms next stop is a machine
called a reheat stretch blow molder
in a matter of seconds it heats each
preform
just enough to make the plastic
malleable
then inserts a rod to stretch the
preform lengthwise
while at the same time blowing in air at
extremely high pressure
this forces the preform into a
bottle-shaped mold
cold water circulates within the mold to
cool
okay so so the reason i want to show you
this is just that
it just gives you a sense of the pace
the pace
now the pace is connected to the
material
and the chemistry and it's it's things
that you already know
right when we did stress strain curves
one of the whole regions of it is called
plastic deformation
these are plastics so
one of the big advantages of these
things is you can make like a small mold
like you do first
and then that can be doled out into
different processes
and and in a matter of less than a
second
with a little heat a little pressure it
can be made into any bottle you want
and then the next one and the next one
okay
well let's see we buy i'm gonna write a
couple of things here
uh let's see we buy
as humans one million
of those bottles plastic bottles
anybody want to give me a unit
per minute
we buy a million globally per minute
now yeah and the thing is if you're
talking about plastic bottles 91
of them are not recycled 91 are not
recycled
um and so my why this matters
um you know it's it's it's going to turn
a little dark right now because
the thing is if you compare with what
nature does
these are nature's polymers and i will
talk about them on friday a little bit
more
and you can say well nature's had
millions of years to work on this sure
nature is the world's greatest polymer
engineer
we are all polymers we are all polymers
right
of different types amino acids sugars
cellulose
right keratin nature does this
in so many ways and of course by
definition these are biodegradable
right now that's what nature makes
here's what we make
now these are this is a beach
that's a coastline right and there's a
lot of places where you can get some
data i like our world and data
you guys can take a look at that and
many other resources here's a beach
here is a guy it's hard to see but he's
actually in a boat
that's a boat right uh so that's all
water
um and of course um uh
then there's there's you know a lot of
information on
lately on things like how how much of
this stuff
uh animals are eating and there's also
a lot of pictures that are sometimes
difficult to see where animals get stuck
in a piece of plastic for example and
that can lead to death or deformity as
in this case
um and and so you know the thing is that
uh we have to think very carefully about
what we're doing
and we have not done that with with
regard to polymers
we have not done that at all
right and just to give you a couple more
numbers right here's a chart
this is how how polymers are used today
packaging is 40 40 of plastic
produced today is in packaging and the
thing is
um that sorry 40 of the pa of the
plastics are used only once
and then thrown away we all know that we
drink a bottle
of plastic you know a bottle of water
out of plastic
or all the way back to the 70s right the
pepsi and the coke
and we throw it away
but the thing is that that most of that
a lot of that most of that winds up in
the oceans
and it takes about a half a thousand
years 500 years
to decompose so um
so let's see a couple more numbers so
first of all
only only seven percent
of all plastic is recycled
now you know coca-cola and pepsi could
recycle could
use a lot more recycled plastic one of
the main reasons they don't is the
the containers wouldn't be see-through
and we can't have that right as can
as consumers we have we got to see it
it's got to be this beautiful clear
uh container but um but
as i said no most most of what's not
recycled winds up
in the oceans and and let's see um
uh in 2050 here's here's one
in 2050 uh the
plastic in the ocean
will equal in the ocean
will equal the weight of all fish
okay that includes whales and you know
large sea animals everyone um
now the thing is that um
let's see many of these plastics like
like polystyrene
there's an example right they decompose
and and so when they're large
large there's a chance to collect them
but
but the sunlight out in the ocean you
know they float up to the top or they
get currents
you know that mix them and the sunlight
the uv energy from the sun
decomposes them now eventually so they
get smaller
and smaller and smaller and eventually
they get really tiny
those are called microplastics you say
well why is that bad because it's toxic
for one thing polystyrene
is toxic the styrene molecule is toxic
it's a carcinogen right it's a
carcinogen
people who eat seafood in some studies
are estimated to be eating 11
000 pieces of microplastic a year right
that's what they're ingesting
today so you know so this is the this
you know this is the problem we're
making these single use products
single use put it in recycling because
i'm a good citizen
but nine out of 10 times it doesn't
matter because it's not getting recycled
oh and then it goes in the ocean where
it stays for 500 years
there's a plastic bottle right there's
fishing lines
so so this is the problem we should not
be
using things on the minute time scale
that then take a half a thousand years
to decompose
and are uh extremely toxic when they do
right this is clearly a problem um
now there are there's a lot of people
working on this and thinking about this
not enough and i want to tell you about
a book that um
that i read when it came out a long time
ago it's a wonderful book and i got
re-exam
introduced to it last week um
it's by david mckay who unfortunately
passed away recently but he wrote this
book called
sustainable energy without the hot air
and
and i highly recommend you read this if
you haven't
it's free it's a free download without
hotair.com
because he just goes through sort of
simply the math
and and the reason i'm bringing this to
your attention he doesn't really talk
about plastics he talks about energy
is is i love this uh discussion in
chapter 19.
chapter 19 is titled every big helps
and he says if everyone does a little
we'll achieve only a little
but that is true we have this way of
talking about these crises
in little bits because it makes us feel
better and it makes companies feel
better
you talk about this but the plastics in
straws has gotten a lot of press
and companies kind of do their part
right
although although starbucks is kind of
funny because they
replaced all plastic straws with paper
straws encased in plastic
that's actually more than the plastic
straws to begin with
single-use plastic again but anyway you
know they're trying they walk away they
say we tried
no because that's doing a little
the plastic in the ocean is 0.03 percent
from straws
right there's so much more we have to do
we can't think little
about problems like this we can't
can't do that um now there are some big
projects there
this is one that's gotten some attention
this is called
ocean cleanup now they've gotten a lot
of attention they've got these rigs out
there
that could collect some of this plastic
in the ocean
uh and it's it's at least thinking big
um there's a lot of bold claims that
they're making a lot of bold claims a
lot of
hype um but at least it's an attempt to
do something big
one of the limitations here though is
this this
technology can't go below a centimeter
it can't go below it's not going to
collect below a centimeter
but but if there are some studies that
estimate that 90 of the plastic in the
ocean
already is below a centimeter and and 60
70 percent of that
has already sunk right
talk about the need to think about this
in a big way
this is a very big problem and i hope
that more and more people get excited
about trying to tackle it
in big ways not little ways okay
oh that was my why this matters nice and
happy
nice and happy why because we're going
to solve these problems
that's why we have to we have no choice
i mentioned there are two ways to make
plastics that i want to talk about
i want to talk about the second way now
so the first way is is called radical
polymerization because i take
one mer and then i make it into
a really long chain the second way
and that right there is nylon by the way
nylon can't be made that way
nylon can't be made that way and and
here's the reason
because in the second way of making
polymers
we take two different types of mers and
this way is called condensation
condensation
polymerization
it's a different way of forming very
very long chains
right so on wednesday we'll talk about
what you can do with these chains how
you can modify the properties kind of
like we did with glass you know we
talked about the fundamentals of glass
and then we talked about engineering it
on wednesday we'll talk about how to
engineer the properties of these
polymers
but right now i want to just focus on
how to make them and so in condensation
polymerization the goal is also to make
these super long strands
but you do it with two different
starting molecules and no initiator
right so how does that work well i'll
take a a
i'll take it i'll get to nylon in a sec
but first let's just take something
called the dicarboxylic acid
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
leave a box inside and i'm going to say
that could be something
right that could be something but i know
that on that something
i've got this i've got a carbon
oxygen and hydrogen and on this side
i've got the same thing
okay oh
all right so i've got the same thing on
both sides
that's a dicarboxylic acid it's
carboxylic acid
okay now on this side
i'm going to have another myrrh and it's
going to be different
and this one i'm also going to have a
box
and on and over here because then tight
i've got nh2 and over here
i've got nh2 and
h2 emphasizing the n is what's connected
to the box there that's why i drew it
that way
and that's called an amine this is an
amine and
and this is called a diamine so this is
a diamine dicarboxylic acid
right and what happens is when those two
molecules so the box can be anything
the box can be
can be whatever for now
but if if it's got those ends to it
if it's got the carboxylic acid and the
amine right so on the one hand the
molecules got
these groups on the end and on the other
hand it's got these
then what happens when i put them in
solution together
well what happens is these two pieces
react
these two pieces react and so what you
get
is let's see you got c
here's my box there okay there's the
o down there and
and let's see okay oh now here's the
carbon
on this side oh boy i'm going to run out
of room and i don't want to
so i'm going to move over here
and recycle these
these boards so that i can draw it nice
and big
okay so now
what happens okay so these are reacting
okay and so now what do i have so i have
c
uh double bond o okay this is my
carboxylic acid there's the box from the
left-hand molecule the one on the left
there here's another c
double bond o but look at what's
happened i've formed a carbon
nitrogen link okay we'll talk about that
in a second
and then here's another box that came
from the the amine
and this is n h
okay and then there'd be like another h
there
and there'd be another h yes another o h
here
okay right
yeah yeah nh2 so i got that back
and what's happened what's happened is
i've made water
i've made water plus i've connected
these two molecules together
right so so if i if i want to be
complete about it i got to add a water
molecule because that's what
happened in the middle here the o-h
group
saw the h on the nh2 group and it said
hey i want to make water
can i do that and then the carbon and
and the nitrogen were like you know what
let me check it out
internally let me check out my lewis
structure and it's like yeah
you can take the oh and the h and make
water because then
we could connect and form this bond here
and that bond is called an amide link
that's that kind and so i formed a kind
of bond between these two molecules
that's
a covalent bond and this polymer
is a class of polymers called polyamide
because you can see now okay i've given
off some water
condensation polymerization but i'm also
now ready i've got my carboxylic acid
and my nh my amine groups there
ready to go again right so if this side
finds
another one of these it can attach and
react
and if this side finds another one of
those it can attach and react and it
keeps going
and going and going
in much the same way it's just now
instead of a radical instead of
initiating it by
by tearing an electron out
i simply have brought together two types
of molecules that want to
in in giving up water react and form a
bond that's very powerful
it's very powerful because i can do
i i can now when i say i said this can
have whatever
inside so now
it's a different way of thinking about
it right before we had the myrrh
and i could make the murder whatever i
want just keep a double bond somewhere
and i can make a polymer that's a lot of
flexibility
now instead of keeping a double bond
just keep these amine and carboxylic
acid groups there
and i can put anything inside the boxes
that i want again
massive tunability and and one of the
funnest things to do is a nylon rope
pull
um we couldn't do it apparently it's a
little dangerous
um oh nylon
is when the box winds up having
carbon chain in it six carbon atoms
and and when this has six carbon atoms
and this has six carbon atoms
that's called nylon six six which some
of you may have seen
right so you so you get nylon
6 6 or sometimes it's just called 66
it's six
carbon atoms
in the boxes well you can imagine you
can make six
eight four six you can play right you
can put lots of things in those boxes
the nylon rope pull is such a cool thing
i had to show you a video
here's what you got you got one molecule
in solution on the top
you tell it's a slightly lighter liquid
and the other one on the bottom
the amines on one side these carboxylic
acids on the other this is nylon so the
box is six carbon atoms
now what's happening at the interface
at the interface this reaction is
occurring
so what i can do and i'll play this is
you can or what this
person can do ah is put a little piece
of glass stirrer in there
okay and pull nylon out
so watch watch how he does this okay so
you get it started
there's a piece of solid coming out of
two liquids
okay what's happening as he pulls it
more is reacting in forming more
of these chains and you can just keep
going
and going and going what's so cool about
this is you're literally creating this
solid with functionality that's tunable
out of these two liquid bats it's all
happening at the interface
where the two molecules the amine and
the carboxylic acid can see each other
there you can see i wish you didn't have
the text there but look at that
you're pulling a polymer right out of
the interface between two liquids
that's how nylon is made and again
this had an incredible impact
on on so many applications i thought i'd
show you this one
that's the first line in new york
to buy stockings nylon stockings and
it's going on and on and on
of course then there are a few other
applications too like parachutes
um and many many many more because again
it's a whole other way
of making polymers now i'll talk more
about this on
wednesday but in your goody bag you've
got
old school fun um and we'll talk about
this in the context of the things we're
going to learn more
about polymers and polymer engineering
see you guys on wednesday
you